hi I think we're just about to start to
live streaming on YouTube as well but if
I could welcome everybody to this BAFTA
master class on composition with the the
wonderful
Hilda guna dirty air who is I think
probably out of everybody working now I
would say one of the biggest
inspirations to me and I know to lots
and lots of other people which is an
embarrassing introduction of course but
I think is makes a lot of sense now
we're gonna do I'll just explain a
little bit of housekeeping today we've
got 75 minutes together and so we're
going to have 55 minutes of conversation
and and with explaining some of the
wonderful processes and we can talk
about Joker and talk about you know ball
and and your previous work as well but
then also we'll have 20 minutes for
questions from from the Q&A panel so if
you're on the zoom chat then down at the
bottom there is a Q&A window if you
would like to enter some questions in
there we'll see what we could make of
them in the last 20 minutes at the end
and but just for anybody who's not
familiar with Hilda's work she's
probably I think got one of the most
bulging Awards cabinets of anybody for
the last year or two from from the
extraordinary reaction to some of the
film TV work that she's done Joker in
Chernobyl but I think for many people
who knew her work before then one of the
fascinating things is for me certainly
is about her development as an artist
and her early earlier work in her
recordings and and and then how that has
become parlayed and and seen in some of
the programs that we see so that's a
long we didn't introduction but hello
Hilde
[Laughter]
it's always it is the the most sort of
kind of mortifying thing to have to kind
of go and they went to school here and
then when they were 17 how we going to
structure hopefully this must just add a
and and obviously you know there's so
much interesting in you talking about
your techniques is we've got a couple of
specific clips that have rather being
sent out invitations to attendees or
will be really on the chat windows as
well one from the bathroom scene from
Joker and then a an amazing scene from a
tattoo in Chernobyl and but I'd really
like to before we kind of dig into their
weeds I'd love to hear more about really
your sort of your how things started
because I know your family was a very
musical family as well so it feels like
you've been kind of swimming in music in
a way right from the very start if
somebody had a small accident you could
still help I think is important to be
connected to your body and connected
that's Spencer part of my process today
that's that's very important it's not we
talked about how we need to nurture
yourself to nurture the music in your
body especially Dupree sitting in front
of your computer the whole thing it's
like it's I find the way to to to access
access ideas and access access this is
all process click happens waivers in the
body I think I think that's fascinating
and honestly as a cellist yourself which
is a sort of kinda over I've always felt
a whole body instrument in a way that
some some instruments of a small and tie
are very you're using your whole body to
play you know you feel it's very much
like at resonance in your chest
resonates in Europe lungs so it goes for
every conversation in the thought
process as well and this is something
that I've been thinking about a lot that
kind of four-block you are within your
within your body
were blocked your thought processes
gonna be and as a composer you know I
think that's a visually there's a
physical process as well because you you
need to be able to visualize what it is
that you wanted to you need to be able
to see you know it's like building a
house you need to visualize a house
before you start putting together you
know and and so do you think this this
this approach which sounds very sounds
very instinctive as well it sounds sort
of not to say it's not cerebral but you
know that there is some physicality to
it was this did it kind of develop
through your teen years was this always
just always how you approached music
because I mean you you did study sort of
classically in inverted commas whatever
that that means but do you think though
that as your paths diverged from from
the more sort of tradition
classical training what were some of
these ideas that you wanted to express
something that's always important to me
but maybe more unconsciously than
consciously I think it's a glue we have
a little chat before this became before
we were talking a little bit about you
know how this is this type of it's I
love there's only bit of space we're
gonna yeah and these these thoughts that
I went through in theater so especially
thinking about few months because you
know we do you know any given love to
neither house access the fluidity that
you normally have with interacting with
people you know it's something that you
started to miss and you realize that
clean weapon what is it happening in
this in these circumstances where
ambition to just be at home and then you
couldn't you start to pinpoint like oh
you know this the document is about
fluidity something that I've been
thinking about a lot the next year in
second
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
from Iceland
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
a part of my process that's always been
repressing music making it in my history
but it's something that I just kind of
started to realize in the later years
like how it's actually the way that you
enjoy you know enjoy resumes which is
ultimately I think what what you're
trying to do when you when you make
music and I mean tries to physically
hear you're happy I see the number again
minutes whether you're having a dialogue
with yourself in a room or director or
it's it's not so much about having like
a wider audience like that's that's them
really been important to me but but feel
that that what we're making is like it's
it's moving
people like speaking to people and
you're near a restaurant with people
when you're ill never even need
having available dicks or whomever and
put a message in a bottle and throw
without them and someone's here you know
you know I think that's absolutely
fascinating because um you know what
we're gonna look a couple of the
specific projects in a moment but I
think what for me anyways is incredibly
illuminating is to hear you describe
that process of flow and communication
and collaboration because it feels like
you've managed to bring that and and
maybe you'll be able to tell us bring
that intact into these films or TV shows
that have reached a very wide audience
but I think certainly from the from the
outside if people first got to know your
work through say Joker which was
obviously you know sort of a global
success then I I think imagining that
that you had sort of set your sights on
on writing Joker and just studied I
think history is to sort of misinterpret
and and and not to understand you as an
artist and you as a person and maybe and
maybe we can move on to it onto Joker
now because I I think we're probably all
read some of the backstory of how you
how are you writing before and how your
your process wasn't necessarily just a
traditional here's the film you've got
four weeks off you go the orchestras you
know waiting for you a week on Friday
and had you worked Wheatley toward the
director before how what was your entry
point into the into the film
[Music]
didier could have gone in your spam
folder
it would have all be very different when
we spoke you know really I just
completely fell another story when he
when he was when he was portraying and
the character study he when he was asked
about this world because it has this
history
[Laughter]
the history of the character how much
this this character means to such a run
into what there's like it's people like
I don't remember any EE like villain in
cinema history or even like fiance too
much to say about literature histories
but comic history like you know
character that people feel so strongly
about feel so strongly about them but
you must character and also portrayals
of this character that we talked about
the people just seem to like you know
feel soft on your heart it's really
interesting to obtain inherently like
that and so deeply rooted for people you
know it means a lot to so many people
and kind of give a bit of a different
take on you know you just said that if
you imagine like you know what if what
if this was his story like one of these
not like you know the personally funny
was you know we really even come from
where is that like you know it's so
interesting with with with characters
like that that have that I've had have
you know they live their own lives maybe
like real life really I just found it
really such a fascinating process that
we have heard of another fascinating way
of storytelling because it's you know
when you when you read the book I knew
even I spent so many hours with the
characters
and you start to make me feel for them
build the characters
yeah just resonate with them you know
when you finish the book you just decide
to have to leave those people whom we've
all had this feeling that the magic of
literature we have this cinema and the
cinema unless you think it's like if we
look at parts specifically the bathroom
scene which is at a pivotal moment in
the film when when Joker has really just
sort of kind of exploded it's like the
initiating action where he's shot but
for anybody who hasn't seen it spoiler
alert well he's shocked kind of you know
the violence inside was broken out and
he shot the guys on the train and and
then he runs through the streets and
then comes into the scene as everybody
will have seen the clip now in terms of
your actual sort of composition process
for this was that a pre-existing piece
that you'd written at the script stage
that then Todd played and tracked in and
if it was did you change it again at the
end did you rerecord how how would you
say you got from no music to there being
music in that scene he continues into
space my feelings
you know just what I basically wanted to
hear what I felt from from from reading
the script and I mean didn't really give
me any sort of instructions or he didn't
you know who was specific about and I
think what they didn't want to go into
his head share from script it was that
we really needed to we needed to follow
him but we needed to be inside kind of
feel what he was feeling
and so I I wrote upon to music and
religiously he loved it you know he we
just believed it did really resonant it
was my everything so we were just it was
one of this just really magical moments
of just complete kind of understanding
of each other's like experiences and it
was just so great to be able to have
that dialogue without any words you know
to be able to just I mean a person worth
of the MER in the script but we didn't
know the need for any explanations when
it hit back and then he took this music
plays his own side so he in the backseat
but keen is responding to this actual
music that we hear of him in the scene
is pretty much this is pretty much
identical to what I do what I did to
movement but but so basically what he
was in to really respond in big to to
lead him through this through the
transformation so nobody needs basically
[ __ ] logistic
villain for the music and everyone was
basically was just like you know so I'm
going with what even when they meant it
to me I was
[Music]
I I know there's a lot of composers on
the on this chat so I might dive into
the technical weeds with you just Ramona
too because it feels like a lot of
composers at at the moment will be using
a computer to to write
and so there will probably be mocking
things up with samples which is sort of
virtual instruments and and then that
will exist as a as a sort of a
representation of the queue for a long
time and then we'll right at the end
we'll go and record with the orchestra
but um I it feels very much particularly
because you're playing so much you're
creating with audio just by recording
yourself or sound what's your blank
piece of paper accessible and very like
DC you know you you're expected to be
able to to to do everything yourself
is if you're expected to be able to play
everything report everything like you
know everything it's a really there's a
lot of steps - there's really like a lot
of steps to learn today and you know
interfaces keep changing you know
programs keep changing you know the now
where I just was like social immediate
local and interacting with
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
the law no the law that you have to
[Music]
I was gonna say about tuning and this is
me being totally geeky is that the sense
of intonation so for instance I think
the bathroom scene is a is a perfect
example the the tuning of those initial
cello notes which played you know very
much without vibrato almost like a vial
you know they have a sort of almost
medieval timer but then because I mean
it it where the fourth sits and where
the fifth sets and and the sitter like
there the way those cards are voiced
they wouldn't sound the same if you just
played them on a human connection to
those two those three unityconnect the
vibrato are like the information things
like information like there's so much we
can express with information that's not
equal tempered straight down the on the
grade so sweet
[Music]
[Music]
and if we move on to Chernobyl which I
rewatched the whole series I watch the
first time but we watched it over the
last couple of days and and to be put
back into that extraordinarily visceral
tense
kind of tragic in the sense of people's
fates are spread out into the future you
know from the moment that they come into
contact with any of the radiation that
you eat each of the people you see on
screen has got has got a tragic future
ahead of them but I wanted to to talk
about how you created there the queues
and and the sort of sounds gates but
perhaps with with relation to to
collaboration and bringing us back a
little bit to it to where we started
because in terms of perhaps working with
the sound recordist like Chris Watson
who we're going to met a new who's an
absolute legend gives the the sort of
the the the big picture of going to
record in a in the disused nuclear power
plant that they that they've filmed in
afterwards and it's the sort of thing
that it's a great idea to have but it's
not always possible to pull off that
well and and you seem to have around you
a team of long-term collaborators
because you must have known Chris from
touch way way back and and then working
with Francesco and Sam I guess well and
you know this sort of and could you
could you tell us how sort of almost
practically what that process were was
like to go and listen and record and
then make music from them at the same
time so I thinking about what was that a
fact it's so many people there are still
very much alive today and it's such an
important like I think
later history and taxes yeah there's
such a huge impact on so many people
that we you know we all know you know
people that is Germany for example
weren't allowed to eat mushrooms because
of you know the facts of aftermath
there's so many so many layers of a fact
so I thought it was really big and
they're not always enough but you know
the people that that lost your night
your you know family members that are
sitting back to that sentence was over
you know I thought it was really
important to be as honest as possible
about what happened there - not like
over drama class like what happens just
an exception and you know so I just
thought that was really from the space
itself got a real place and a real voice
and another space had to be and the
radiation which of course is like you
know the biggest characters in this
story but the radiation also have a
motivation for suspect you can see if
you let them capture it but but we can
summer feel it and we can sense it
because that the radiation wouldn't need
to be present and so it seems like very
obvious to just go there to understand
also myself to be better like what
radiation feels bad about it when it is
to get into to formally sort of opinion
from myself about this you know I had to
be experienced so so I Monday with
prison
we got so much amazing material from
there so we create these things and that
process I can lick it was a very
it was like as far away from I recognize
that door squeak that's door 17b from
the dt so if we if we take as a for
instance because there's it sounds like
you enjoy very much these long periods
of exploration and but then there comes
the day of reckoning where episode two
needs locking and it needs to be sort of
sent to the Dove if we look for instance
at the cue that we just picked out which
again is another sort of sensational
piece piece of drama it's it's not so
much that necessarily this sort of
virtuoso scoring with a massive
orchestra hopping up and down it feels
so much more integrated and and your
the lines between water sound design
elements what are musical elements were
musical sound design elements all are
very fluid but if you took a scene like
that would you be starting with with
effectively just that two three minute
sequence and would you then start to
play sounds to fit or deep were you
taking a cue that you'd written in the
weeds because
[Music]
[Laughter]
I think that difference which which
isn't all not every younger composer
who's necessarily familiar with in terms
of the decision making and the the
number number of opinions that you might
have on a project and and there's
there's a a sense of I think T V in my
experience has it has a sort of a
particular going for the wrong decision
maker trying to please the wrong person
in telly is is a very bad mistake
because there are those layers above
often who you need to bring along with
your ideas what have you found over the
projects that you've done that you have
have developed any sort of political
strategies or do you just try and stay
just open and communicative or do you
let other people do that and do the
late-night phone calls
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
do you find did you find yourself gang
unsettled on either of those projects do
you do you have i'm i'm smoothly
segwaying into into some questions
because they've been some wonderful
wonderful questions in on youtube and on
the zoom chat and there's from John a
Kunis from Australia says
have you had developed any daily rituals
to get you into that fluid state
mentally and physically and and I think
that the the subjects broadly of mental
health and dealing particularly with
those pinch points that you described
tasty sometimes yes you also have to be
very careful not to be because these
last minute conversations can can easily
become very heated it's very important
to not like react too fast or too
strongly to situations like that until
be able to to distance yourself from
like you know snappy reactions like you
have to between the only thing that
keeps any of us together is that really
I think you know your past is so it's
such a magic - yeah and you're in your
songs and you know extending being being
a part of that practice it's also very
very very very valuable in the process
and I think also the more you can bring
it into into
just be part of your creative process
yet I totally agree and that reminds me
to start meditating again because I
stopped when we had our last baby and
I'm broken now my headstone place and
again so needs so many beautiful
questions I'm going to sort of like
stick a couple of them together here
this is a from Katherine and YouTube and
and she just says add there any her
question was about female composer
support groups and companies that you
recommend but I just wanted to to blend
that in with a remark I heard you make
on on another interview I think which
was about describing at the time at the
moment as a big awakening and whether in
terms of just I think when you when you
probably made that remark it would have
definitely been pre covered and would
have been pre black lives matters and I
think it was it was just as phrase that
you used where you described the sort of
the the change in after the me to you
movement as a big awakening and it's and
without sort of you know wanted to kind
of count count numbers also to go back
and go who first one what when it's just
interested in Europe your experiences as
a woman composer right now
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
it was too heavy for you to pick up yeah
three three four years or so it's gone
from people being unsure whether they
should trust a little fork for the job
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
definitely Bravo
could I are gonna join a few more
questions together and ask you about
life in Berlin so obviously Iceland was
originally home but you you've settled
in Berlin and being there for
for how many years now for clip again
quite a few and and it's been a couple
of questions asking about your Han and
the we see greatly greatly missed and in
a way maybe a sort of framed those
questions about what it was like to work
with him in the wider context of what it
was like and what it is like to be part
of a musical community in in Berlin
itself having when we know some of the
same wonderful people and worked in in
some of those places and and it feels
like there is there's a collaborative
spirit with not just some of the
composers like just in your hand a whole
wonderful community yeah being in
collaborating so we were yeah we started
collaborating in the nineties just
through
in 2003 we started like our our first
collaboration with we just had a
recording session in this kitchen
yes and we basically just never stopped
to meet we just we really kind of you
know an internal front our musical soul
mates you know and so we just continued
collaborating since since that since
that kitchen recording in 2003 we have
to the very last thing and it's very you
know very almost people imagine like
Dustin Sisco you know so part of that
dialogue side so I moved to Berlin in
2003 as well so I met Francesco here
young one who was able to use to
Copenhagen and came to Berlin just like
minded people you know people they
couldn't have what you call it before
like the watercooler as a compulsory
know that this being a Cabrini an only
job when it is so great to be able to
have a dialogue with people that
understand
yes and you had a question this worth
sadly very sadly coming sort of
reasonably close to the end of our time
together which is for me a personal
personal shame because I I think many of
your ideas that you embody about flow
and improvisation and collaboration are
really important and and I think you're
extraordinary and well-deserved success
one of the byproducts of that is that
these ideas which which I think are
crucial and a great antidote to some of
the sort of kind of harsh ways of living
in film composing necessarily get more
attention which is something that I'm
very grateful for you for being so
brilliant and and making them sort of
letting these ideas have the attention
that they have but the final questions
will be the traditional sort of career
advice questions which I always find
confusing because like what would you
say to somebody who was just starting
out but if you're just starting out it
it's such a vulnerable time it's so sort
of trying to find there was several
questions about finding your own voice
but because I think you embodied that up
beautifully but there's a question here
from one from Sophia Lloyd just the
second part of the question we said if
you could tell your younger self
one thing about female composers what
would it be or just to broaden that out
if you could just tell your younger self
anything useful that you've learned how
might that look you know finding the
voices and
and and those kind of general career
questions I think it's I think it's
really really really crucial it's really
important that's the most effective
pound and way of yourself is that it's
so important to to listen to little it
to to listening is so so crucial and
that goes for like listening to just a
couple you know when you're having a
conversation with someone when you're
having a dialogue with someone you know
may be collaborating with and also just
listening to yourself absolutely
but tuning is make yourself a truly
respecting what it is that you're
hearing and not like you're not
listening to to what it is that you
think you should be doing or what's cool
of the world with terms like the right
processes because it's like oh saying
before like I think most people you know
there's so there's so many preconceived
that is about how you're supposed to do
music but music is such a and it's just
a form of expression and I think there
shouldn't be there shouldn't be a right
way of expressing yourself like there
shouldn't be as long as you don't
turning anyone with what you're saying
and as you're learning that people with
your actions there shouldn't be any
I mean restrictions or really express
yourself but I think the way that you
express yourself and music is best
suited in the way that really resonates
with you personally and I think it takes
a lot of time and practice to be able to
hear anything like even in that
direction really stick with the practice
and you have to kind of stick with just
showing up and showing up again so this
is like I said I mean I've been I've
been doing music professionally my coach
for 20 years
only first level that you know I'm
getting any real recognition that's
really never even in my kind of a
monitor or point of doing it but I put
it took a really long time before for
you know meet you sexually not showing
up and doctor to be able to to be here
myself and I think just needs and then
it when you know for anyone else to hear
me and I think and I think today is just
like the music industry's is a very
confusing place of room it was the one
fighting rappers in the world we can't
have concerts anymore it's it's just
like a very confusing time in music
history
it's more important than ever
[Music]
no one has the same voice every voice is
different and that's just something that
should be not only respected and
celebrated I think it's worth the wait
well I think that's an absolutely
wonderful beautiful and rather moving
place to end Hilda thanks so much for
taking some time out to chat to
everybody thank you to everybody who's
joined us on on the chat room whether
unzoom or on on youtube I believe that
the session will be available on youtube
to watch afterwards if you want to
catch up on some of the things that um
that Helders mentioned and if you want
to reach out to either of us on social
media or on the on the usual ways if
there if there are any names that
perhaps that we use that that we that we
didn't explain or any any other
information then then I certainly
volunteer to be findable and I volunteer
Hilda not have a break but thank you
very very much indeed
thanks to everybody we're gonna wind up
here and and say goodbye to everyone and
I'm hoping one of our hosts from from
BAFTA will pull the plug and thanks very
much to BAFTA for hosting this because I
think it's wonderful to have had such a
wide-ranging and I'm very I think
fruitful and warm chat so thanks thanks
very much thank you
it's the zoom wave this is how you have
to finish your [ __ ] car hopefully
they'll stop